if you're in desperate straits if your
life is falling apart if you're
nihilistic and miserable and maybe you
have your bloody reasons because maybe
you do
that's still the case that if you step
outside yourself and you try to make the
lives of other people better that's the
best possible thing that you can do for
yourself it's defining you know what we
what thomas jefferson wrote the
declaration of independence this this
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
and you know those are those words get
thrown around a lot and some people
might say well pursue my happiness that
means pursue whatever ends i want right
pursue whatever
it gives me that short-term
gratification
pursue whatever makes me
just feel good and i don't think that's
what the founders meant um and there's a
lot of evidence for that because what
they meant was the pursuing of purpose
you know the idea that that some sort of
purpose in your life is what what makes
you happy and that
and that there's there is a given set of
traditions and social interactions and
and standards of living
that genuinely make people happy
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased today to be talking to
congressman dan crenshaw who i've had
the privilege to get to know
over the last couple of years now
most recently
congressman crenshaw
set up an event for me in washington
where i had the privilege of speaking to
a large group of republicans
concentrating on policy making about the
possibility of generating a
positive message going forward
as a
bulwark let's say against the
possibility of a kind of reactionary
populism which is not
optimal unfortunate for everyone
concerned
dan and i talked after that about doing
another podcast concentrating on
political issues particularly
focusing on
the danger posed by the radicals on the
left and the radicals on the right he's
had a lot of experience with the
unpleasant radicals on the right i
thought that would be really interesting
but
over the last few days i've also read
his
book new book
fortitude
something dan knows something about by
the way fortitude american
resilience in the age of outrage and i
really liked the book i thought it was a
lovely balance of
story personal story
concept
uh
encouragement
clear delineation of a political and
sometimes a theological philosophy
psychological philosophy so i took a lot
of notes and i thought what i would do
after i read
dan's bio is walk through his book with
him
there's a lot of places where our
thinking
dovetails i suppose which is why it's
easy for us to get along
and i think we could have a very
productive discussion as a consequence
so i'll start with the bio
originally from the houston area
representative dan crenshaw is a sixth
generation texan in 2006 he graduated
from tufts university where he earned
his naval officer commission through
navy rotc
following graduation he immediately
reported to seal training in coronado
california where he met his future wife
tara
after graduating seal training dan
deployed to fallujah iraq to join seal
team three his first of five deployments
overseas
dan was medically retired
in september of 2016 as a lieutenant
commander after serving 10 years in the
seal teams
he left service with two bronze stars
one with veler the purple heart and the
navy commendation medal with valor among
others
soon after
dan completed his masters in public
administration at the harvard kennedy
school of government
he then returned to houston
where his community had been devastated
by hurricane harvey
inspired by their subsequent volunteer
work dan and his wife tara decided that
the best way to serve the people of
texas
would be in elected office and so in
november 2018
congressman crenshaw was elected to
represent
texas's second congressional district
in congress he serves on a number of
important committees including the house
energy and commerce and the house select
committee on the climate crisis
as well as the health and environment
and climate change subcommittees
so congressman crenshaw thank you very
much for agreeing to talk to me again
that's much appreciated and uh
kudos on your book how's the book doing
by the way
a pleasure to be on jordan appreciate it
uh let's do it
it did really well um it came out
it's a little old at this point um came
out in 2020
and uh it did quite well um
because
it wasn't a political book i think um
there's definitely a ceiling for
politicians to write a book as far as
how many a ceiling as far as how many
they'll sell
yeah i think we did much better than
that simply because it's not a political
book and it's not even a seal book
it's a little mix of all of those things
but mostly it's a uh
like you mentioned earlier it's an
ethics book it's a it's an empowerment
book it's a self-help book it's lessons
and fortitude and it also happened to
come out at a time right in the
beginning of the pandemic which was uh
i i think a prime time for those kind of
lessons so it did pretty well
yeah well the book starts with your
discussion of both victimization culture
and outrage culture
and you
you make a moral case i would say
against both
uh and also i would also attempt to
do a diagnosis of why this has become
front and center in some sense and so on
the victimization
front
you you make a case that
in some ways
the sense of victimization and the sec
the sense of oppression and
and uh
is
opposite to the
to a proper sense of gratitude and duty
and i thought that was extremely
interesting because
obviously there are
situations where people feel as if
they're being oppressed
justifiably
but you can make much of that in a way
that's not productive and
by dwelling on that especially
if it's not
deserved let's say you also deprive
yourself of the values of duty and
responsibility and that's a way to
undermine the meaning of your life in a
most fundamental sense
you deprive yourself of
of
the you know
what's the word i'm looking for you you
deprive yourself of any ability to
overcome it right you depart you deprive
yourself of agency
and that's that's a devastating thing
psychologically for someone
if they're deprived of the tools and
the abilities to move forward past
whether that trauma is real trauma
whether that victimization is justified
as you said because i mean there's two
types is that the narratives that get
built in our society about victimization
uh which can it could certainly be
debated whether it's real or not and
then there's true victimization and true
victimhood
or at least being a victim of some kind
of injustice but victimhood yeah i would
say is a bit more of a mindset and you
you can either live that way or you can
or you can
decide to overcome it and decide that
you indeed are in charge of
your own destiny
yeah well there's a difference i think
there's a difference between
being a seeker for justice and
construing yourself as a victim
you know if you're a victim in some
sense
you're owed something your own redress
but if you're a fighter for justice then
your decision is something like
that you're going to move forward
to help yourself and others
despite
the injustices of the world that's a
better way of thinking about it so you
get your agency that way without
falling into that that pit of envy that
that victimization also seems to produce
you also have to define justice
correctly and i think that that's where
our our society has has qualms with one
another is
this redefining of the word justice and
what injustice actually is and so i
there i think there is a classical
definition of justice and it's and it
usually sounds something like this maybe
it's uh maybe it's a violation of what
we would consider due process
um and we all have a pretty good idea of
what due process is based on english
common law and our own constitution and
and a lot of court precedent
um
another way to define injustice might be
the the
granting of
some kind of status
for any other reason besides merit right
maybe maybe it's maybe it's heritage
maybe it's maybe it's a good old boys
club whatever it is that would feel like
an injustice and you'd be right about
that
fundamentally injustice would be
infringing on
someone's rights right person a
infringing on the rights of person b on
their life liberty or property that
would be a certainly american classical
way of defining an injustice
and in infringing on especially
inalienable rights these negative rights
um the left does not define justice that
way the left has come to define justice
a very different way
uh for instance instead of negative
rights proposing
that it's an injustice if you are not
getting positive rights and by positive
rights they mean services
they mean that there's an injustice
against you because you don't make the
same money as someone else is an
injustice against you because your house
is smaller than someone else there's an
injustice against you
uh for
for because your health care is too
expensive they consider these things
injustices now
it may be the case that we want everyone
to have health care and affordable
health care back
but that doesn't mean it's an injustice
and when you start to use those kind of
those morally fraught words you make
people really crazy and you go down a
path
where you're you're demanding so-called
rights for someone
and that necessarily involves coercion
coercion's a pretty bad path to go down
because you then have to literally
infringe on someone's rights in order to
provide someone else the same kind of
services so while it seems like
splitting hairs this sort of redefining
injustice it's actually pretty important
and it has pretty serious consequences
yeah well if your definition of justice
is predicated on something like a notion
of equity
no one can have more than anyone else or
it's unfair it's unjust the net
consequence of that is no one gets to
have anything at all
because there's not even a hypothetical
way that we could distribute all things
equally to everyone at once that's
literally impossible and so it seems to
me that the price of some prosperity for
most is that some are more prosperous
than others and then hopefully to the
degree that that's also just
some of the reason for that excess of
prosperity is also a consequence of
of let's call it effort and ability
and that's a form of justice too
it certainly is and like in the book and
when i'm looking at this these
victimhood narratives that are so
pervasive and how that's related to
outrage culture first of all feeling
like a victim makes you outraged i think
that's that's a pretty simple path to
draw there
but i i think what's worse about what
we've seen recently is the elevation of
victimhood
uh to where it's
you know you you talk about heroic
archetypes a lot i i took a lot of
influence from you actually in that
chapter right when i talked about who is
your hero and and and what does
self-improvement look like well it looks
like copying people who did really well
and maybe not in everything they do like
if i want to be a great singer a great
pop star maybe i'll look at taylor swift
but i'm not going to look at her for
literally anything else
so it's identifying the attributes that
make someone successful within a given
hierarchy
that's that's fundamentally what
defining your heroes looks like in a
very practical way and so i fleshed that
out but what concerns me is that this
elevation of victimhood and you know
jesse smallette was a great example of
that because he found it so compelling
to pretend to be a victim that he would
actually create this whole
crazy conspiracy hires two people to
beat him up just so he can claim that
these you know mega people beat him up
you know
that's a pretty shocking story but
what's more shocking is the the
underlying incentives that are prevalent
in our culture that's what actually
scares me
and
i see it on the right now too when i was
writing this book i didn't see it as
much on the right
um since i've written the book i do see
it on the right and i want to lay out
some some sequence of events for you and
you tell me who you think it applies to
so step number one
say something very provocative crazy
mean stupid whatever but say it and say
it really loud step two watch as
everyone reacts to what you just said
and then feigned disbelief that they
would be so obsessed with you that they
would that why are they talking about
you
number three claim victimhood because
they're attacking you right they're the
ones paying attention to you and you're
just trying to you know speak truth to
power or whatever
then use that victimhood as a club to
wield and a tool to beat back your
opponents and maybe that's through a
fundraising email maybe the person who
said the provocative thing is a
politician or maybe maybe they're a
podcaster maybe they
they have an influencer page on
instagram and now they get more
engagement because they're being
attacked because they said something
provocative and crazy that's a sequence
of events that you can see um
on both sides right
if that sounds a lot like aoc you're
right if it sounds a lot like margery
taylor green you're right
because they both do it and i think
they're quite self-aware of it but it's
a scam
yeah it's a claim of unearned moral
virtue and you know i've been thinking
about this a lot i thought about it
again reading your book so
we all compete for reputation
and
that competition can take place many
ways the proper way for it to take place
is that we compete
on grounds of productivity and
generosity it's something like that
and then
if we establish a very positive
reputation as a consequence of our
productivity and generosity
then we're stably placed in a functional
social hierarchy and we're surrounded by
people who
will trade with us and will respect us
and will treat us properly and as a
consequence
our negative emotion can be controlled
so imagine you're virtuous and so now
you have a stellar reputation and the
consequence of that is that your nervous
system views your positioning in the
hierarchy as a consequence of that
reputation and decreases your stress so
then when when you go after someone
someone's key beliefs the things they
stand for hypothetically you're
threatening their reputation and then
you threaten their position in the
hierarchy and then you threaten their
emotional regulation that's the chain
the problem with all that is it can be
gamed
and because there's nothing more
important than reputation
and by the way we pay attention to
people who have a good reputation
because there's nothing more important
than reputation people are
motivated and willing
to take shortcuts to attaining it
and that's the yeah that's the issue
with virtue signaling and so you say
well you can point to an injustice
suffered on your behalf
and that elicits people's sympathy and
then you can claim to be a moral
crusader whether or not that's true and
then you
adopt the cloak of
reputation
and then you
ratchet yourself up in a manipulative
manner up the hierarchy of of
of social security and esteem
and that's the narcissism machiavellian
psychopath game
and uh
it's a game that threatens societies all
the time it always has
we'll have more with representative dan
crenshaw in just a moment but first i
want to tell you about birch gold
experts warn that president joe biden's
plan to forgive student debt could cost
over 500 billion dollars their solution
to hire 87 000 new irs agents and
squeeze taxpayers with an additional 1.2
million audits per year there's never
been a better reason to diversify at
least some of your savings in precious
metals and protect those savings in a
tax sheltered retirement account with
birch gold group
text jordan to
989898 and birch gold will send you a
free info kit on how to diversify into
silver and gold tax free
birch gold has an a-plus rating with the
better business bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers
text
j-o-r-d-a-n-t-989898 to claim your free
no obligation info kit on how to protect
your savings with gold
text jordan to 989898
i think so and i see it in politics
quite often i'm amazed by
some of the people i thought i was close
with who
who betrayed me or turned on me for the
smallest of gains
i mean you created an enemy for life for
for the smallest of gains i would almost
be more understanding of it if they
gained something huge from from doing
what they did to me and i can i can
point out various cases it's just
unnecessary but it's it's the incentive
structure unfortunately in in politics
because
that kind of conflict uh gains people's
attention
and attention is currency in today's
political atmosphere because we we have
unfortunately devolved into sort of this
jerry springer rock and soccer politics
it's tabloid politics it's this news of
the day politics as opposed to
taking a step back and arguing over some
very fundamental differences and ideas
and governing philosophies like
there are some proper debates to be had
and
look sometimes they do get had but
it's not what people are interested in
um if they if these if these debates get
had at all it's it's it's because the
people you elect are actually doing
their job uh in committees and going
through the hard work
but it's not glamorous and they get no
credit for it the people who get credit
are the ones who don't bother with any
of that boring policy stuff but who
instead come out and yell and scream on
the house floor about something or other
and gain a lot of attention and that's
currency
yeah well it's very difficult it's very
difficult to keep that sort of
the attention that outrage can generate
it's very difficult to keep that under
control
especially when it can spread so rapidly
let's say on social media systems now in
your book
you talk about the alternative to
outrage and victimization you talked
about outrage as something like a
combination of wrath
which is a cardinal sin and envy which
is a cardinal sin and pride which is a
cardinal sin
it attracts a lot of attention it's what
elevates you morally in the face of your
victimization and you segue from that
into
well into your experience in iraq
in
and
you're the terrible
the terrible medical problems the battle
injuries that you sustained as a
consequence and you talked a fair bit in
there about
how it was that you were able to not
construe yourself as a victim and one of
the things i found so striking in that
section uh
was
the credit that you gave to your mother
and the example she sent you you know
you talked a little earlier about
finding heroes or about identifying your
heroes it's like
one of the things you can do to identify
a hero is
not so much seek out for someone that
you'd like to emulate in a voluntary
way but to watch yourself
and see who you involuntarily admire
just because of the way they are
and you make a very you make a repeated
case that that was
the situation with your mother so maybe
if you wouldn't mind you could talk a
little bit about that and then about how
that experience
shaped your ability to deal with
catastrophe in your own life
well you know the the title of that
chapter is perspectives from from
darkness and i i mean the word darkness
quite literally in this case because i
was blind
um from the explosion um this was in
2012 uh in afghanistan we were on a sort
of a
unplanned mission
uh it's not really worth getting into
exactly what we were doing why we're
there but it was afghanistan and it was
hellman province so you can imagine it's
a bad place
and there's a lot of ieds there's ieds
everywhere in
southern kandahar and helmand regions
and uh one of my interpreters stepped on
an ied right in front of me he got all
four little four of his limbs blown off
right away and i got knocked on the
ground i didn't quite know what happened
i immediately felt for my legs so that i
knew that i wasn't the one who was who
had stepped on it but i knew i was hit
with something i could hear him moaning
in this um
you know people people think that in
because they watch war movies and when
somebody gets their guts blown out or an
arm blown off or something a lot of
times in war movies the person is
screaming um it's not really accurate
it's far more accurate when the person
is sort of walking around in a day is
kind of like moaning
and it's it's a much deeper pain you
can't scream you can't possibly have the
energy to scream
it's it's a much deeper
moaning
groaning sound that you just never
forget i've heard it a few times
um
so i heard that and i i put it together
what had happened and
um
nothing you can do at that point i i
actually was in complete denial i
thought i just had dirt in my eyes so
i couldn't see anything but i didn't
have a lot of pain in my face in
hindsight just because it would have
been so numb um but i had a severe pain
throughout the rest of my body because
it was you know
frankly the brunt of the blast was lower
to the ground and so it hit the lower
extremities of my body much harder
just for anyone who's curious i was
wearing kevlar underwear so you know we
i was miraculously okay there but uh but
heavy heavy scarring everywhere else um
and i for some reason just never
believed i was blind and even when i
woke up never really believed i was
going to be blind they told me the bad
news of course when i woke up about five
days later
um
they put me to be clear they put me into
an induced coma on the on the air on the
medevac helicopter right when i left
that site so i was conscious throughout
the whole thing i remember it pretty
well
uh
but i was gone i was out for five days
after that
woke up in germany
and you know got all the news but for
some reason kept a spirit and then
and then there's and then there's that
next step which is well i guess it's
time to start feeling sorry for yourself
because your life has changed pretty
dramatically and
you know this this kind of self sense of
self pity is
it's like a warm cozy blanket you can
wrap yourself in it and
you can think about how
everybody else on the team may be
screwed up or how maybe the mission
itself was screwed up maybe you can turn
it into some some
statement about foreign policy and
endless wars and there's there's no
there's no end of reasons that you could
claim victimhood and i've unfortunately
watched some veterans get into politics
and do exactly that
but it's pretty unhealthy and i can't
imagine being happy doing that and
if i had to look to one person who had
gone through severe hardship throughout
her life it was my mother
and she got cancer breast cancer when i
was five years old and she eventually
lost that battle when i was 10.
but
in hindsight i never saw her complain i
never saw her cry to us about it she
never lost her temper with us when she
really should have in hindsight because
i'm not sure we were the greatest
but
the amount of grace and grit that she
demonstrated it had always stuck with me
maybe it got me through other hard times
too maybe it was always subconscious i'm
not sure in any case
it's
it's a model and what i encourage people
to do is if maybe you don't have it's
unlikely that you have that model in
your life to that extreme extent and
thank god for it because that would
really suck if everyone had that
particular experience
um but you do have stories
um you know because again there's real
heroes that you know from your own life
there's real heroes from history and
then there's
fake you know
make-believe characters i i mentioned
superman as as one of those make-believe
characters he's like this he never says
or does anything wrong and for some
reason you're drawn to him and then you
have to start asking yourself why am i
drawn to this person and maybe that
person is your boss or a leader in the
military or superman
but you're drawn to them for some reason
and it's worth doing some introspection
and thinking to yourself what are the
traits that this person exhibits that i
can emulate and be better as a result
right well and we should we should point
out here too well that's also the case
like
we should make a very clear
uh
distinction here that
often when people are embittered and
resentful and feel like they're victims
it's because really awful things have
happened to them now not always but
often and so then the question is well
if you're in a situation and something
really awful is happened to you or has
happened to you then
well why shouldn't you feel like a
victim and is there a better alternative
and part of what you were trying to lay
out in this part of the book is what
those better alternatives are so part of
looking for that hero is to find out
from someone else's example in your case
it was your mother but these other
sources that you described
of people who were
in a sort of hell
in an undeniable sense but who chose in
a very real way
to make it as good as it could possibly
be given the circumstances and so they
had to turn to
sources of power let's say in strength
and fortitude and resilience that
weren't
in some sense obviously associated with
the catastrophe i mean
in your mother's case
it's pretty tragic situation she's a
young mother she has young kids now she
has breast cancer and she fights a
losing battle
over a period of five years that's
pretty
bad
and then you have to ask yourself given
that that's obviously pretty bad
how is it even possible that someone
could handle that with
not only grace and courage but the kind
of grace and courage that leaves their
children with an un
what would you call an an immovable
sense of the ability to prevail in the
face of the deepest adversity i mean
that's really something you said here
thousands have come before you and they
did just fine
so quit your complaining and it's not
because you have nothing to complain
about that's not the case it's that
that's not the right approach
the fact is
and this is such an optimistic fact
as well as a judgment in some sense the
fact is that if someone else can do it
so can you
and that's something right if you're
reading about the great heroes in
history people who are in these terrible
situations and you see someone rise to
the occasion
and then
you can say well that was a person who
did that and i'm a person and so maybe i
have that capacity too even though i
don't know how to approach it and then
some of the rest of your book much of
the rest of your book i would say in
some sense is
a guide to help people figure out how
they could approach that one of the
things you you point out first as well
pick
notice who you admire
and then maybe
try
consciously practicing
becoming like that
you said i had many defensible reasons
for bitterness
after greet and grievance after getting
blown up
and losing an eye while you were face
down after your surgery right you were
face down and immobilized
for six weeks you said you couldn't even
move your neck because otherwise you
might go blind which is like a good
reason not to move your neck and you
were all
all blown up on the front uh on the on
your on on in your chest and so forth
and so you're also laying on these
wounds
and so
how in the world did you manage that you
had your wife that was obviously
extremely helpful
well
oh yeah and i'll talk about that it's um
yeah six weeks was a long time
and the reason you're lying on your on
your stomach
you have to be face down it doesn't
necessarily mean you have to lie on your
stomach you can in theory walk around
you just have to be looking down the
whole time it's not like your eye will
pop out if you you know take a break and
you're allowed to take a couple breaks
and you know naturally sleeping you it's
very difficult to do this and so you're
gonna roll over
um the reason you do it is because when
you when you do retina repairs uh they
they need to put a band-aid of sorts on
your retina and you can't stick a
bandage on your retina of course so what
they do is they stick a gas bubble in
your eye
and you have to face down so that gas
bubble presses against your retina holds
it in place um
it's uh it's quite the surgery and in
fact i had a much worse surgery a year
and a half ago i went blind again
because my retina fully detached this
time uh due to the scar tissue from that
earlier blast and so bam i was right
back on my stomach a little easier this
time because um
i didn't have all the other wounds you
were referring to uh and frankly it was
a nice break from politics if i'm being
perfect
[Laughter]
yeah i was really really tired the only
time i fully detached uh you know so to
speak
so you know and i want to hit one one
thing you said just one more time
because it's important as a foundation
and that's what i try to do in the book
is foundations our perspective and these
heroes and from there now it's time to
start giving lessons on how to be those
heroes but the perspective part is
important and that quote you read is
important and i say it in speeches a lot
too if i'm giving sort of a
non-political speech they'll say look
here's the truth whatever you're going
through now you've probably been through
something more difficult so deal with
this
now it may be true that you've actually
never been through something more
difficult but here's another truth
somebody else has been through something
more difficult and they've dealt with it
a lot better than you're dealing with it
now
yeah that's a that's a that's a hard
truth but it's yeah but it's a it's a
but it's also an optimistic truth right
because when you see someone in the
depths of genuine suffering hopefully
what you're trying to do is to throw a
lifeline and one possible lifeline is
compassion
and that's probably the right right
lifeline to throw an infant you know
who's suffering that sort of
overwhelming compassion but
for someone who is an adult or or making
progress towards being an adult the
lifeline that might be thrown is
there's something within you that would
let you be more than you are and much
more and maybe enough more so that you
could actually
deal with this suffering so it didn't
turn into hell and take everything along
with it
and that's there isn't anything more
optimistic than that you say something
here which i think is extremely i'm
going to read something from your book
here
it is true that character is to some
extent innate
i would say what that does is that it
provides each of us with a range of
talents and a
range of temptations
and something like that so it's the hand
we're dealt and there's certainly a
genetic element to that our genetic
makeup imbues in us certain proclivities
but it is as true that character is
mostly a consequence of choices
strangely enough we all make them and we
should make them deliberately
with the knowledge
that these choices are part of our
responsibility toward a purpose other
than our own selfish aims that
responsibility is to your family friends
community and country that's something
that conservatives
put forward as
a pathway to virtue you know and what's
so interesting about that as far as i'm
concerned as an antidote to atomistic
liberalism let's say
that hyper privileges the individual is
that
it's definitely been my observation as a
clinical psychologist that in the depths
of misery
the capability that you have to be of
service to other people your family your
friends your community your country
that's actually a saving grace under
such circumstances you know that people
really find a deep and abiding meaning
in that service so it's not just finger
wagging
and
the pointing towards duty it's like no
no you don't understand that if you're
in desperate straits if your life has
fallen apart if you're nihilistic and
miserable and maybe you have your bloody
reasons because maybe you do
that's still the case that if you step
outside yourself and you try to make the
lives of other people better that's the
best possible thing that you can do for
yourself
and so i really like that
it's defining you know what we
what thomas jefferson wrote the
declaration of independence this this
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
and you know those are those words get
thrown around a lot and some people
might say well pursue my happiness that
means pursue whatever ends i want right
pursue whatever
it gives me that short-term
gratification
pursue whatever makes me
just feel good but but there's a
difference
that's what right and i don't think
that's what the founders meant
um and there's a lot of evidence for
that because what they meant was the
pursuing of purpose
you know the idea that that some sort of
purpose in your life is what what makes
you happy and that
and that there's there is a given set of
traditions and social interactions and
and standards of living
that genuinely make people happier um
one of those you mentioned is doing good
for others yeah some kind of kind of
service having having some kind of
responsibility to feel useful and so
it's
it's not
we we rely on the bible a lot for these
this this moral framework but you don't
have to if you don't want to
because you you can look just like basic
psychology i think to derive the same
conclusions there just happens to be a
lot of truth well one of the one of the
one of the conclusions that you can draw
and we know this
psychologically and
psychophysiologically now we know what
neuropharmacological
it's known from multiple dimensions
simultaneously that
the system that produces happiness let's
say in the founders sense
produces that emotion in relationship to
the observation of movement towards a
valued goal
and so so you can derive some
conclusions from that the first is that
without a goal there's no happiness
by definition because happiness marks
movement towards a valued goal the next
is
well
the higher the goal
the more
value there is in the
observation of movement towards it
and so out of that you might ask well
then what's the highest goal because why
don't we go for that
well then you could say well
you should do your best for the best
you might say well that's just to make
me hedonically happy it's like well wait
a second you know
cocaine will work for that
because india actually even activates
this system but what about tomorrow and
next week and next month
and so
the problem with hedonism as a goal is
first of all it vanishes when you're
suffering but
even
failing that
if you're serving yourself hedonically
in the narrow sense it's just about me
and my pleasure it's like okay which you
today's you tomorrow's you next week's
you next month's you
what about next year five years from now
10 years from now you're going to lead a
hedonic and dissolute life and what are
you going to be a burnt out shell and a
wreck
a dismal wreck in 10 years because
that's what will happen and so
if you don't construe yourself as a
community stretched out across time then
you're not even serving yourself and if
you do construe yourself as a community
stretched across time then serving other
people and serving yourself turn out to
be exactly the same thing
i have a question for you as i was
hearing you go through this and uh
maybe i would have liked to maybe flesh
this out in the book but but i didn't um
i'm also not a therapist so probably
best that i didn't try but how do you
how do you advise people on on how much
they should give in to their to that
pleasure seeking that short-term
gratification just for the because it
does seem to me that just for the sake
of sanity there has to be some balance
there it's very difficult
to to to be to be perfect well it's a
mistake and you know one of the things i
just did a seminar i just did a course
on the sermon on the mount
and christ in one of the uh one of the
sections of that sermon he says to
people that
you shouldn't lose your saltiness you
shouldn't lose
your savior and
and you're the salt of the earth and
without that salt everything loses its
flavor and salt is a preservative and
it's a spice and
that's often
uh conceptualized that phrase as
referring to the salt of the earth you
know the st solid reliable types who
bear all burdens but that is not what it
means i looked at a lot of different
translations i talked to a lot of people
about that verse and really what it
means is
well there should be some
spiciness and unpredictability and humor
about you
and there should be some play in the
system right because that's what stops
you from just being the narrow dead past
letter of the law with no spirit there
should be some snake inside the tree
right there should be some fire inside
the bush those are all ways of of
construing that that are symbolically
equivalent there should be some dynamism
in you and a fair bit of that's
associated with
well enthusiasm that's fun but
enthusiasm means to be imbued with the
spirit of god that's why people like
comedians so much too because that's
what they do
and so you have to leave in the duty
with humor and you your book does a
lovely job of that too because your book
which is very conservative book in in
the best possible way
and is a call to duty and responsibility
but you constantly return to themes of
both stoicism and humor which are tied
together in some sense you know i i was
just in newfoundland for the last week
doing a documentary there and
newfoundland's a rough rock and it's
beautiful and harsh
and the people there are tough and
resilient man because they had to be
and
newfies have a great sense of humor and
they're always
making fun and
that
that's a necessary level right
that that that
that ability to
deal with serious matters in the light
in a light with a light touch
and
it's something i'm trying to learn to do
more and more even in the most serious
of conversations you know too because if
you're a master you've got both you
you've got that light touch and that
sense of humor you really see that
military people who've been through
rough situations i was going to say that
the best kind of humor is dark military
humor and it's
it is not for public consumption but it
is yeah because it's it's everything
that it's supposed to admit it's
offensive it's
and it's
it's dark um in ways you can't even
comprehend but yeah and unless you've
been in that unless you've been in that
darkness so you said here too let's go
for another quote here
throughout your life this is very
practical advice too and i think it's
very wise from a therapeutic perspective
throughout your life
you have people you look up to okay so
let's think about that you look up what
does that mean why up
well up is something that beckons from a
distance it's like a light on a hill and
we automatically assume that those
who we admire are people we look up to
so that specifies a a distance and a
direction and it's uphill it's up toward
a higher vista let's say so there are
automatically people who
who elicit that spirit in you you have
noticed the way might also imply might
also imply that there's some sense of
struggle required to get to that point
because it's easier to go downhill than
it is
yes definitely that's right it's an
uphill it's an uphill trek and it's also
implies judgment because if someone's
above you
then they also serve as a judge or you
serve as a judge in relationship to them
because you compare yourself
unfavorably with them and that can also
inspire you to tear them down that's
really the story of cain and abel and
that's that's a major story
you have noticed the way a teacher
parent co-worker mentor or friend
interacts with others and you come away
thinking hmm that behavior simply works
better
they are respected admired
and successful
and you find yourself wondering why that
is you do if you're a little bit humble
instead of being envious right because
otherwise you think that damn crook he
just stole his position and that's why
he's got it but if you're a bit humble
you might think well no that guy looks
successful maybe he knows something i
don't
you are noticing attributes and
character traits that are good
and worth aspiring to you are noticing
attributes that make certain people more
successful than others
you are noticing
what a hero looks like and in the
process you are discovering a path
made up of desirable personality traits
that helps you ascend
in social hierarchies that's jacob's
ladder by the way that
that ladder that is the hierarchy to the
good
that's the vision jacob has
of the pathway to god is that it's a
hierarchical structure with the thing
that's ultimately good at the pinnacle
by definition right the best of all
possible goods and then there are
intermediary structures all the way up
and
beings inhabiting those structures and
this isn't metaphysical it's like if you
find someone you admire the reason you
admire them is because they're higher up
in that heavenly hierarchy so to speak
than you are and your whole nervous
system tells you that
you're compelled to listen you're
compelled to pay attention by your own
by the action of your own unconscious
mind
you know what's interesting about this
point of identifying these heroes or or
at least role models you can call them
either one i just thought heroes was a
more compelling word to use
for for the sake of writing it but
what's interesting about it too is how
pop culture actually plays a pretty
important part of this because like
there's plenty of people who simply
don't have these good role models in
their lives and you have to acknowledge
that
and so where are they supposed to turn
and it's maybe one of the reasons that
it's so important to fight these
cultural wars that you and i engage in
on a fairly regular basis that they
become a serious part of our politics
which at this at the same time is
necessary but also deeply deeply
unfortunate
um i do think i do think the the attack
on pop culture from this this
progressive victimhood left has reached
a reached a ceiling
i think there's a there's a serious um
backlash
uh i you know you look at movies like
top gun the recent one
maybe like the highest grossing of all
time absolutely phenomenal movie really
fun to watch why
because it just had all of these
classical virtues
and infused within it about
relationships and about how you treat
people and what the consequences are for
treating people as such that these
things speak to people in a deeper way
they can't necessarily articulate them
but they get they understand it when
they see it
and there's these sort of radical
minorities that are very loud that want
that changed you know they want
something else
to be on that hill
but people react against it because it's
not it's not true there's no truth to
that yeah well yeah and something cries
out from inside of them then and that's
and that can be appealed to by a
storyteller i saw the same thing in the
marvel avengers series is that there is
a return to any
any
wide range of classical virtues
certainly brotherhood uh a kind of a
military ethos
sacrifice
a striving upward certainly masculine
virtues the combination of the hulk and
iron man for example that's a that's a
that's a that's a there's a monstrous
element to the hulk but he's a hero in a
strange sense and he's also the
revitalizing force for iron man when he
just about dies and
and that's all the reason those movies
were so necessary and so attractive is
because they are in fact addressing a
radical conceptual void in the culture
and it's a void that well that you're
addressing in your book especially with
your appeal
well trifold appeal let's say to duty
responsibility and humor at the same
time right which is a kind of stoicism
in the face of catastrophe here's a
here's a model
so
for everyone who's listening and
watching
you know if you don't know
what you should do with your life you
don't know who you should be sometimes
you think about that as what career you
should pursue but here's another way of
thinking about it it's kind of a seals
ethos that
congressman crenshaw detailed out
here's some things you could be
those are my words these are his
you'll be someone
who's never late
you will be someone who takes care of
his men gets to know them
and puts their needs
before yours
you'll be someone who does not quit in
the face of adversity
you will be someone who takes charge and
leads
when no one else will
you will be
detail-oriented which you discuss a lot
in later sections of the book always
vigilant attentive you will be
aggressive in your actions
but never lose your cool you will have a
sense of humor because sometimes that is
all that can get you through the darkest
hours
you will work hard and perform
even
when no one is watching you'll be
creative and think outside the box
even if it gets you in trouble
you're a rebel
but not a mutineer
you are a jack of all trades and master
of none
and then you follow that a little later
with this paragraph
these paragraphs be aggressive enough to
kill the enemy
but immediately calm enough
not to scare
little old lady
you'll be that man who's mentally tough
enough to operate in horrific chaos then
immediately transition to tranquility
all
without mentally breaking
you will effectively transition from
hyper masculine aggressor to gentle
caretaker you'll be both a warrior and a
gentleman
the qualities that made seal leaders
great
were rarely
physical in nature
they listened
they empowered their team to be
successful
carefully entrusting individuals
with additional responsibility it's a
real conservative ethos there they
highlighted good performance publicly
and criticized bad performance
privately
and so well you know those are lists of
virtues and maybe they're not the only
list of possible virtues probably not
but if you're lost and you don't know
where to start
practicing you know you also talk about
this idea that uh
this is an aristotelian idea you know
that we we are our habits we become what
i what we practice and if imagine
if you're lost in your listing you think
well you find some things admirable well
you could practice those things and you
can practice them locally and
minimally
in your own relationships and you can
start to get good at them and as you get
good at them well you get better at them
right and then you can you can broaden
out the scope of your action into a
wider purview and like i just
i just can't see how you can go wrong if
you're miserable
by
starting to work hard on making other
people's lives better
especially if you do it to some degree
in secret you know without trumpeting it
yeah and and then and then
being able to deal with it when
you're not necessarily rewarded for it
right away
um
it's certainly true in politics you know
what what you were reading there was
yeah a combination of i think some
general advice but also the warrior
ethos which is a little bit more extreme
right this this this ability to move
from chaos to tranquility very quickly
it's just it's always a phrase that
stuck with me maybe from bud's
instructors um
as we were going through training
which is they're always telling you
who they want you to be
and
and it's a mission statement right it's
an ethos and there's a seal ethos
which is a little long to read but it's
it's it's incredible because it's
telling you
who you should be not not what you
should do necessarily not
what outcomes you're looking for and you
know you tell this to corporations who
have a mission statement on their
website they're going to be like the
number one seller on the west coast well
that's an outcome you might be looking
for but that's not telling you anything
about who you want to be
yeah and and if you don't if you don't
tell that to the team
they have nowhere to aim for they also
can't switch outcomes when it's
necessary you know so because this is a
big problem in life imagine you're
aiming for something and then something
happens to make it impossible or you
find out that it's the wrong thing
because you're aiming in the wrong
direction well so then what do you have
to rely on to set your right
it's not your aim obviously but it might
be your capacity to take new aim and
that's bloody well dependent on your
character that's for sure and so i don't
think there is a more
fundamental aim than what you should be
and there's no fundament no better way
of characterizing
what you should be than that you should
fortify
your
character
also worth noting the outcomes you want
will come more easily if you're if
you're striving to be something that is
that is a known good
that is of good quality at least and
you know i i hope this book at least
details some ideas of like what that
what that better person might look like
and yeah well certainly untrue that i
live up to every one of those points
that i just discussed
but we're all sinners but that's also
part of the point of an ideal right i
mean the ideal should be beyond you or
what the hell kind of ideal is that if
it's not an uphill walk then there's
nothing to do and of course you're going
to be in sufficient relationship to that
you you list some other attributes here
too that that all that all continue with
here
and uh
you want to be someone who could take a
joke that's an amazingly important thing
eh that and it's it's been so
interesting to me especially when i
interacted with
with
with like physically laboring men in
particular who have very very difficult
very very difficult jobs
and military jobs can be paramount among
those is that
that's a prime way that men size each
other up it's like
i think the question of whether or not
you can take a joke is something like
are you humble enough to be able to
rapidly and with good humor admit to
your own stupidity
and in a fundamental sense right because
if you do something funny people will
call you on it's like look at how
useless you are and you go yeah yeah
yeah look i'm pretty you think that's
useless here's something else i did
yesterday that was like twice as useless
as that
and then people think oh well he's not
afraid
he's bigger than his flaws
yeah and he's secure you know there's
there's a sense of insecurity when you
when you can't take a joke now of course
the the
the partner of that idea would be tell
good jokes okay yes right there's you
know if you're gonna if you're gonna hit
somebody for something make sure it's at
least twenty percent funny
uh and not just insulting and that
requires judgment it requires a bit of
balance and and practice uh to be honest
timing crack you know
and just just being in those moments um
i
my sense of humor is perhaps a little
too dry and sarcastic for some
especially outside the military
but you adapt and you learn and you take
social cues and you will become better
at this
shouldn't shy away from from humor
because it i it's hard to imagine
anything that gets you through difficult
times better than humor yeah well that's
a lovely thing if it was true isn't it
that that there isn't anything better to
get you through difficulties than humor
it'd be lovely if the world was actually
set up that way you want to be someone
who can take a joke you want to be
productive
yeah the best definition i ever read of
christian charity maybe just of charity
in general
generosity
plus productivity
and look people like to stress the first
especially when they aren't the second
it's like i'm generous it's like yeah
but you don't have anything so that's uh
you know now i'm not talking about the
people who truly have nothing and are
still willing to share
i'm talking about the people who
pull down the productive
while hyping their own generosity and
forgetting that
you'd be even better at being generous
if you were all so productive
so i hear from socialists a lot that
that jesus was a socialist this is a
common refrain from from the progressive
left and the idea it's not true that you
should want to give charity and i said
jesus wasn't saying that you should take
from others and make them give charity
that wasn't what is he said you
need to be generous with your with your
belongings with your time with your
labor that's what he was saying it was a
generosity of the heart not a not a
demand on others that's right well it
was at that it's absolutely 100 correct
it's an injunction towards the highest
form of self-sacrifice
period the end obviously that's what the
crucifixion means the acceptance of that
catastrophic death all of that what
would you say the tragedy of life and
then even a further radical acceptance
of the of the necessity to confront hell
that's self-sacrifice that is not
calling for
moral actions on the part of others on
your behalf definitely 100 percent not
and that self-sacrifice is called upon
even if you're innocent
right so it's even more than that
you want to have the ability to delay
gratification you know that that ties in
with what we talked about earlier about
being able to treat yourself as if
you're a community across time because
to delay gratification means to
sacrifice
you the hedonism of the present to the
security and iterability of the future
and so that is a hallmark of maturity
that's also the ability to
make sacrifices that's why the
sacrificial motif is stressed so hard in
the old testament
you have to make sacrifices
to what well
to whatever you value well what's the
highest value well by definition that's
god so do you sacrifice to god well if
you sacrifice at all you sacrifice to a
god
maybe you don't sacrifice well then
you're immature maybe you sacrifice to a
lesser god then maybe you should get
your act together that's all tied
together integrally with the notion of
the ability to delay gratification
that's why god tells adam and eve that
they're condemned to work when they get
thrown out of the garden of eden it's
like well now you have to work because
you're aware of the future
well that's a call to sacrifice because
work is a sacrificial act
and then the question is in service of
what and there's another chapter in the
book called do something hard
it's very pretty direct and it's
straightforward there but what we're
getting that is that is that there's
there's
there's a problem in our society where
we we do our best to alleviate any kind
of suffering as if we as if we feel that
there's this you that there's this
utopia available to us where suffering
can be completely removed from our lives
but that's a false promise that's a
false god
it's it's impossible and and worse than
that
it prevents that sacrifice that you're
talking about it prevents that uphill
climb because people feel are are told
to feel that there's some sense of
injustice if you have to
work harder than anyone else for
something up for something and
you know and and and they they're
blinded as to why and look maybe you do
have to work harder than someone else to
get to the same point not saying that's
impossible but
we all do that's that's
you know that's true for all of us right
because with our genetic inheritance
let's say some things come relatively
easy to us and some things are virtually
impossible and have to be strived for
mightily and i'm also not saying that
some people aren't
what would you say condemned in some
fundamental way in multiple dimensions
simultaneously i mean i've had people in
my clinical practice and met people in
my pr private life who's
who are burdened by so many difficulties
simultaneously that it's almost
incomprehensible so i'm not saying
there's something even-handed about this
but
all of us have to
work
very hard on certain fronts to be better
and to do better and it's also not
obvious to me that that's actually
that's an unbearable price in some sense
but it's also the most fundamental
disciplining adventure
right and we know i know i don't know
what it's like for you i suspect it's
the same but when i look back in my life
i think
when i'm thinking in a positive way i
think well that was really difficult
but it was worth it
and those two things are integrally
associated right because you don't
generally say well that was easy but it
was worth it
you know i
and so what that seems to mean is that
the difficulty
is intrinsically bound up with the
reward
and then of course we know that right
because how how happy are you
even for someone else when you see them
overcome immense odds
to attain something of value
everyone stands up and cheers when that
happens you know that's every that's
every feel-good family movie every ever
made
and i think one of the hardest parts
about this concept is choosing which
suffering to engage in like which
challenge to embark upon and i think
it's a it's a bigger problem for my
generation in particular
they
because we see everything on the
internet and we we see how quickly some
people made it
and then we feel behind if we're 10
years older than that let's say
and so there's this
and i and i wonder if that's what's
behind the the millennial habit of
changing between jobs extremely rapidly
it's hard for people to commit to a
certain place because they're so unsure
if this is worth it if this maybe they
are engaging in the challenge maybe they
are working hard but they're unsure if
it's worth it and you know and i don't
know how to give that kind of advice i
don't i don't know what the right path
is for you what i can tell you is if
if you're giving 90 instead of 110 that
whatever it is you're engaged in now the
opportunities to do what you really want
to do probably won't materialize i i've
got another
principle there too
if you're uncertain about what you're
doing
and you don't know if you should change
course
set yourself the obligation to choose
something more difficult before you
change course because there's a moral
hazard right it's like well am i am i
unhappy or am i just useless
it's like well a little of column a and
a little column b well how do i
fortify myself against my uselessness
i don't allow myself to switch course
unless the challenge increases
and that works you know it's it's a
check against your own
laziness and inertia and envy and
resentment because you know then too you
can say to yourself
well i i moved from there i didn't fail
i didn't quit i chose something more
difficult and so i can have some
faith in my choice
maybe maybe i can have some faith in my
choice because you accepted a bigger
challenge
we talk about quitting this gets to
another chapter called no plan b
and um what i lay out as a concept there
is not necessarily that you shouldn't
have plan b's as
defined as contingencies in your life
you should always have contingencies but
there's a mindset where that contingency
becomes a crutch you know and i talk
about this in in terms of seal training
called buds basic underwater demolition
slash seal training that's the
that's the famous training that
everybody's familiar with with hell week
and the boats on your heads running
miles and miles getting wet and sandy
and coming in and out of the cold
pacific ocean
that's buds
and if you go into buds with with an id
any other idea then you will die before
you quit then you will probably quit
because
the contingency is pretty obvious it's
warm coffee and donuts if you just go
ring the bell three times and you say
you've quit that's that's your plan b
um you will reduce your suffering to a
minimum if you do that
uh but if that if that is truly an
option for you in your in your head
then you'll probably take it
uh especially in the face of great
adversity which which which is training
certainly is yeah and so plan b doesn't
mean
don't have a backup plan it does mean
have a mindset where you're gonna aim
higher where you're to aim for your
fundamental purpose and and quitting is
a tricky word because really you know if
you quit changing courses as you
mentioned it's not necessarily quitting
you know i already point out
you think you want to be an artist and
this has been your dream for for god
knows how long but honestly you suck at
it and that is your talent just cannot
catch up with your aspirations and
that's a reality you know if you move to
something else does that make you a
quitter
i'm not sure i'm not so sure it does
yeah exactly well then that's just
learning from experience
you know and
i was thinking when you were talking
about no plan b i thought oh yes well
that's marriage you know because the
great psychologist carl jung he thought
well marriage has to be an unbreakable
vow
why
because you have to be in 110 percent
and if you have a backup plan which is
well if this doesn't work out i can
always find someone else it's like when
adversity comes which it will
because you're bound together with this
person for life and life is adversity
then if you have these lurking this
lurking way out you're not going to do
the work necessary to struggle through
what you have to struggle through to
continue to forge the relationship with
your wife and so we even know this i
would say clinically in some real sense
so imagine there's two competing
hypotheses one is
well
you have to learn to be married and
maybe you should give it a trial run and
so it's before you get married which is
this full 110 commitment with no plan b
you live together
then you learn if you're compatible and
if it works you proceed to marriage and
in that case if that theory is right the
people who live together before they got
married would be less likely to be
divorced
but they're not
they're more likely to be divorced
really absolutely and i think the reason
for that is because they were testing it
out the whole time well it's hard to say
it well that's that's one one
possibility is that people more likely
to get divorced are also more likely to
live together right so they just don't
have as much respect for the conventions
but the other possibility is well what
are you saying when you live with
someone what are you really saying and i
know what you're saying i know what it
is it's like i find you
acceptably attractive
for now
but there's some real possibility that i
could do better and maybe you could too
and if you'll allow me the possibility
that i can trade up i'll allow you that
possibility and in the meantime we'll
just exploit each other and see how it
goes it's like well how the hell are you
going to forge
a lasting relationship on that basis
you know maybe it has to be something
like
well i'm pretty bloody thrilled to have
you given all my flaws and
hopefully you feel the same way about me
if i'm fortunate and let's go all in on
this like a hundred percent knowing it's
going to be a catastrophe because life
is a catastrophe we're not going to step
outside
we're going to make the best of this and
we're going to swear to do that because
that'll give us the fortitude necessary
to actually
be desperate enough to make it work and
so that's no plan b man and
it doesn't mean you should die if you're
you know if you're
if your marriage happens to well if your
partner dies for example it doesn't mean
you're obligated to end your life or
anything like that but there's lots of
games you can't play if you're not all
in
i i i it's a great point um
on marriage it's funny because uh my
wife we took wedding photos
on the buds grinder which is sort of the
the central location of this hellish
training that happens and and inscribed
in a big plaque
on one of the walls there is a famous
seal quote no easy the only easy day was
yesterday
and it's it's
speaking to a major truth i think in in
combat and seal teams which is don't
rest on your laurels everything before
you thought that was hard just wait till
what's next and you're just it's just
mentally preparing you for it and sort
of tongue-in-cheek we took a wedding
photo in front of that sign because it
maybe it applies the same way
well it does apply in the same way i
mean the thing about being married to
someone is that
you face the worst of life with them no
the best perhaps as well and maybe
that's dependent on how well you face
the worst but
if you have a mistress it's all parties
and roses you know at least in principle
because you don't have to do anything
difficult with that person you parse all
the difficulty off to your poor wife
who has to bear the responsibility of
the catastrophe of the children's lives
and and the domestic economy and the
fact that she has to live with you and
all the things that go along with that
so she has all that burden and this
other person is just a vacation it's
like well that's not a very good plan
and and how in the world can you
you have to swear fealty to someone in
order to abide by them
when
the catastrophes come to your door and
the thing is man the catastrophes are
going to come to your door and
if you want to be alone and miserable
when that happens
then
i guess you're going to find out what
that's like but if you
if you have that bond that won't break
then
maybe you can
you can guide each other through the
darkest places
i'm going to read something else you
said here
and
this is very very much worth stressing
why duty and how is that associated with
happiness well maybe we find our
happiness in pursuing our highest duty i
was reading exodus did a seminar in
exodus in miami last week and i had
great scholars there to help me walk
through it and
one of the things that's very
interesting about
exodus is that when god tells the
pharaonic tyrant to free the israelites
he always uses the same phrase and you
only ever hear half the phrase
he has moses say
let my people go
now you hear that phrase all the time
but you don't hear the second half of
the phrase which is repeated i think
nine times one for each plague perhaps
ten times because there's actually ten
plagues if you count the devastation of
the firstborns that's the tenth plague
god has moses say let my people go
that they may serve me in the wilderness
and that's really interesting eh because
it's not and dennis prager pointed out
that the word freedom isn't used once in
the exodus narrative
and it's because
the free freedom from tyranny isn't
hedonism
it's not the blind pursuit of passions
it's the
servitude to a higher purpose
proper freedom is servitude to a higher
purpose voluntarily accepted servitude
to a higher purpose perhaps the highest
purpose which is what god calls the
israelites to and you say in your book
here
purpose is meaning
that's a hell of a thing if it's true
purpose is meaning especially if you
find purpose and duty and responsibility
and i think you genuinely do in
sacrifice i think that's true
deeply true
purpose is meaning and meaning is
happiness
we don't think about happiness enough
and when we do we do not necessarily
think about it properly happiness is
neither joy nor entertainment
it is an ontological condition
fundamental to our existence as humans
it's notable that when the founders
drafted the declaration of independence
they listed up front three things to
which we are all entitled life liberty
and the pursuit of
happiness
a little later you say
you need to understand that your purpose
may be great in the eyes of the world or
it may be commonplace and seemingly
seemingly small
your purpose might be your family your
children
it might be tutoring a child and
changing their life
it might be the business you started
it might be cleaning up your block
it might be in the help you give others
it might be in the example
you set
and then you say
as john adams said
our constitution was made only for a
moral and religious people it is wholly
inadequate to the government
of any other
and so i love the way that was that's
all tied together you know that
happiness is to be found in the pursuit
of meaning and purpose and that's tied
up with duty and responsibility
responsibility to others i think that's
fundamentally true
and i do think that's the way out of the
deepest suffering
and then the idea that
accepting that striving for it
individually is the precondition for the
survival of a constitutional state like
the u.s i think that's also
that's literally metaphorically
theologically and philosophically true
as well as well as politically
right and you know bringing the politics
into this that's
it's it's fundamental and it's it's part
of the fundamental battles that we have
right now um
you know there's there's definitely some
truth to the idea that if you're looking
for that proper moral framework and that
proper path toward happiness
um the christian the judeo-christian
tradition is a pretty good place to look
for bats
and even if you're not a believer and
many people are not
it's
it's hard to deny that that same moral
framework isn't used that you use it on
a daily basis to to do good and to make
yourself happy
and
i think there's been a movement real
quick for quite a long time um ever
since marx
wrote his his famous works that i think
set off this revolution or maybe was
since the french revolution in 1789
maybe that's the real start of it where
this this hubris takes over this
ingratitude for
what is tried and true takes over
and the the
the the worship of reason starts to
occur this is the french revolution of
course and where where they they tear
down these these iconic christian
symbols and replace them with the with
the idols of reason and worship that
instead we worship our own ability to
create our own utopia and it didn't turn
out so well
um and recently it happened again in
2020 where you you you get these uh
autonomous zones that were created in
places like portland and seattle they
called them chaz it really was
in the end it was all just a good laugh
for the rest of us as we watched this
the complete chaos um unfold in front of
us
but a chaos that was that was guided by
this
by this
highly irrational but also
um highly egotistical and narcissistic
idea that you could find your own utopia
and do away with any of the institutions
and traditions that
that laid the framework and play the
groundwork for where you are today
and of course it ended in chaos and um
and and had to be there was murder uh
murders happened in there the drug use
it was just complete
nonsense and it's certainly not what the
founders meant by the pursuit of
happiness and i know we already talked
about that you have another quote here
from
john paul ii
a generation back in 1995
saint john paul ii reminded an audience
of americans at camden yards in
baltimore
that the meaning of those necessary
tasks and responsibilities
is the very essence of our national
character
every generation of americans needs to
know
that freedom consists not in doing what
we like
but in having the right to do
what we ought
that's a lovely phrase that to have the
right to do what we ought right so
that's such an interesting twist on what
freedom means and it is very much akin
to this idea that
god frees the israelites so that they
can serve the highest purpose in the
desert and you think well what in the
wilderness well the wilderness is the
wilderness of the soul obviously in
in despair and
and catastrophe that's the wilderness in
exile
you want to serve what's highest in that
situation
because that's the way through that's
the exodus because exodus means ex-hodos
which means way forward the way forward
out of the desert and out of the tyranny
is by
the adoption of the highest possible
level of responsibility
and that's the right to adopt that
responsibility is there for the science
what is it san quentin is that the right
word of freedom not the freedom to
engage in hedonistic excess which isn't
a freedom at all it's just
self-destructive you know psychopaths
say they don't learn from experience
they're really hard on their future
selves
they have to move from local to locale
because everybody figures them out
like they betray themselves just exactly
and as badly with their hedonistic
pursuit of power and
and licentiousness they betray
themselves just as badly as they betray
everyone else and the clinical
literature on that is crystal clear
and some of them are in politics but the
uh
now the
that quote's important because it gets
to the idea of ordered liberty which is
fundamental to the american sense of
freedom and you know i i i think we've
fleshed out pretty well at this point
freedom is freedom has a deeper meaning
than just hedonistic pleasures and
short-term gratification
and the american experiment is
fundamental to this this idea of ordered
liberty i always point to the to the
statue of liberty as some good symbolism
for this because she holds her her torch
which is supposed to illuminate the path
towards freedom but nobody really sees
what she has in her other hand which is
a tabula on sarah it's a book of law
and inscribed on that book of law is is
our our independence day july 4th 1776.
and that's interesting i think that
symbolism is interesting because one
she's it's it's a book of law so it is
it is this idea that you can't really
have freedom
unless there's some sense of law here
because if you have anarchy of course
the the natural extreme there is anarchy
and
hard to be truly free and anarchy
because there's a high there's a high
likelihood that stronger people will
just infringe on your rights and destroy
you and end up in this sort of
post-apocalyptic warlord scenario
but authoritarianism is of course the
other end of that in which you clearly
don't have freedom either and so ordered
liberty when this and this social
contract where people agree to live by
some sense of moral standards and then
the question is where do we get those
moral standards from
and i think that's why we put in god we
trust those words on everything from our
coins to our dollar bills to described
right above the chair of the speaker of
the house
oh no you know an order ordered liberty
a walled garden is ordered liberty
that's a standard image of of paradise
it has to be culture that's the walls
right and then it has to be
freedom
natural freedom even within but but it
has to be balanced and and
and and it has to be balanced in a way
that's that signifies the deepest
possible meaning that's another thing
that's very interesting psychologically
is
what's the phenomenology of getting the
balance between order and chaos right or
between law and freedom let's say and i
know the answer to that the answer is
meaning
because that's what meaning signifies so
when you're gripped by that sense of
meaning this is literally the case when
you're gripped by that sense of meaning
what your nervous system is signaling to
you from the lowest steps is that
you're somewhere
secure enough so you don't have to be
panicking
but on the edge enough so that you're
maximally learning
and so you're you're benefiting from the
walls and the rules that's the
predictability but then you extend
yourself out into the unknown and when
you do that enough your interest
intensifies and your attention
intensifies and your engagement life
intensifies and if you do that maximally
well then you're on the line between yin
and yang right hey jonathan pagio told
me something very interesting about this
is so cool this just blew me into bits
when i heard it
you know when the israelites are going
out of
uh
out of egypt into the desert after the
red sea
god appears to them as a column of fire
at night
and a column of cloud
during the day and i asked pajar what
that meant because i couldn't quite
figure it out and he said well it's the
same thing as the yin and yang
is the calm of fire is light in the
darkness and the column of cloud is
darkness in the light it's shade and the
provision of of of what would you call
protection from the sun when it's too
bright and then at night the fire is
what lights your way and so you have
these two pillars
they're just like the two circles in the
indian yang and if you're guided by the
light at night and the darkness during
the day balanced in proper proportions
then you're on god's path out of the
tyranny in the desert it just blew me
away because
right there you have the union of the
taoist philosophy and the
judeo-christian philosophy and in a
single dramatic image
it's absolutely it's absolutely
spectacular that that was like one of a
hundred things i learned at this seminar
but that's so cool eh if you imagine if
that was really the case is that
you know when you're suffering and
miserable
there's a potential pathway of meaning
that beckons forward even in the depths
of that misery and that's if you can
find that it means literally means you
found the pathway out and that's
the pathway that's marked by the proper
balance between predictability and
unpredictability and law and spirit and
structure and fire and tree and snake
all of those opposites they all line up
and then that
imbues you with the sense that your life
is
worth it
that existence is worth it despite the
suffering and the malevolence it's
phenomenal man it's phenomenal literally
phenomenal yeah
and there's a it's the balance of
politics too or at least it should be i
mean what we should be arguing about
when we argue in politics is
this this balance between chaos and
order
and there's this balance between too
much order and too much government
control
you know based in this idea that you the
government can create this utopia for
people based on based on this idea that
the government might even know what
utopia is for everyone right and that's
that's that's the amount of hubris
involved in that and that presumption is
enormous and on the other side this this
idea that
well you know you should just let
everyone be free and and you know
hedonistic or anarchic in a sense and of
course the balance is the right place
for that
if i write another book i think it would
be about
defining this philosophy of freedom and
how we think about it and how best to
obtain it
um
maybe that would be a good place a good
direction to go but fundamentally that's
the and it's it's thomas seoul's
conflict of visions the unconstrained
versus the constrained vision this
unconstrained vision being that there is
no limit to what government can
accomplish if we just do it together and
we just want the nice things okay that's
the unconstrained vision
and the constrained vision is a little
bit more humility about what we think
government can accomplish to make your
life better to help you pursue your own
happiness
and so the conservative angle on this is
have a sense of gratitude for
institutions that existed before us
uh know the know the foundations that we
stand upon to be where we're at right
now and know that we want to reach
higher and that it might be difficult to
reach higher but do not set a flame the
foundations beneath you just because you
haven't reached that higher point yet
which i believe is what the left does
and the unfortunate reality on the on
the far right would be
they have begun to agree with the left
that that any problem with an
institution means it must be torn down
immediately
um you're seeing that you're seeing this
with the military you know because
there's some woke problems in the
military you know it's it's true i'm
probably
one of the people on the on the cutting
edge of this trying to fight it and and
actually get examples of it send them
send them to the department of defense
so that they know the problem from the
top
but but on the radical right what they
would want is to just defund the
military
defund our military vote to defund the
military because they're doing silly
things and silly diversity and inclusion
exercises for some soldiers which are
stupid and they should go away
but does it mean you tear down the
institution itself
similar with media people people see and
have good reason to distrust certain
media outlets
um and they make mistakes they they
construct narratives that are that are
false
does it mean you never trust anything
again from any of these outlets
no it means you should be skeptical but
there's a difference between being
skeptical and the desire to completely
tear down an institution because the
problem that i see
is that because people don't just
because people distrust some of these
legacy media outlets they now think that
the truth must lie
consequently in the deepest darkest
corners of the internet and the most
random of websites that you've never
even heard of where it's usually some
you know 21 year old trying to cut their
teeth and get some kind of
sensationalist headline out there
that's not true either
yeah well you see this odd this odd
rising
conceptual problem on the right and it's
something i've been observing that's
made me concerned about
it's one of the concerns i have about
about trump's strategic approach let's
say
you know he he appealed to a sense of
resentment and a sense of desire for
justice on the part of the excluded
working class i think the democrats made
a catastrophic strategic error throwing
the working class to the wind and i
think the environmentalists are doing an
even worse job of that now
and trump appealed to them which is odd
because
what was odd for a whole variety of
reasons but but he did appeal to them
but the appeal has a danger right the
upside is
he's a man who is is hypothetically
standing for a movement towards justice
and even inclusion for the working class
but the but that can easily slide into
an appeal to resentment and and the
appeal to resentment then starts to
become identical with the appeal to
resentment that's made by the radical
left and it touches on the issues that
you raised which is well the
institutions are so corrupt that we
should just tear them down you can't
trust the politicians you can't trust
the media you can't trust the judiciary
it's like
okay
how are you different from the radical
leftists that
like aren't you just and aren't you by
saying all that
aren't you also saying that they're
correct
and then i have another comment about
that maybe you'd like so we could we
could go in two directions here i've
been thinking a lot about about trump
and his brand
and what it means for the republicans
and
for me trump part of trump's attraction
was that he was trump
even in that literal sense right he's
the guy at the top he's not the sort of
guy that a low-level operative can screw
around with he's a guy that gets things
done he's not the guy that has things
taken from him by fools
he's the guy who can see what's in front
of his eyes
he's a guy you can trust in
in
as a what would you say an icon of
competence and stability in a sea of
chaos that's his brand
and then the election doesn't go so well
he loses
and then he says well it was stolen from
me and i think well every political
system is subject to a certain degree of
corruption and the margins of victory
are small
and so
leave the leaving that aside for a
moment it's like i thought you were the
guy that this sort of thing didn't
happen to
i thought you were the guy who couldn't
have things
stolen from him easily
i i thought you were i thought you were
the guy who didn't
turn into a victim when
he didn't get what he wanted
and so now that's a big story right the
election fraud and that seems to be the
basis of his hypothetical return to the
political scene and
jesus that's pretty dismal story
and i think it's going to have an even
more dismal outcome if it if it prevails
what you said
earlier about the uh
the the claiming that you know yeah the
the courts are corrupt the system is
corrupt this is corrupt that's corrupt
politicians are corrupt
you're completely right in that it it
ends up justifying the left's position
fundamentally because it becomes this
sort of outcome-based philosophy as
opposed to a process-based philosophy
conservatism is a process-based
philosophy
where
we believe like
the point of being a politician is to is
to adhere to and construct a
governing system that allows us to
disagree and then reach a point of
consensus to the best possible way
that's that's the point
um but the more that people believe that
the point is is really beating the other
side and then twisting institutions in
order to do so
well it shows that you don't have any
respect for precedent
or unintended consequence consequences
and that's our criticism of the left
because we're like okay you want to pack
the supreme
court well how do you think that's going
to go when we take over so what by the
end of the decade we're going to have 30
supreme court justices how's that going
to go that's a conservative way of
thinking or you're going to remove the
filibuster then what do you think that's
going to do when we take over we're
going to destroy you
and we didn't remove the filibuster
because we didn't want you to destroy us
you know and in the election thing this
has been a problem with everybody i mean
it seems this is a new i don't know how
new it is
but it got extreme obviously in the most
recent election but stacey abrams still
claims she won the the governorship of
georgia
and this tit-for-tat this escalation
ladder that's occurred on both sides is
unbelievably toxic and it's made them
both look like the same people i could
list a whole number of ways by
disposition where i think the radical
right is the same as the radical and i'm
not sure trump is the face of the
radical right the way i define them
you know
it's almost like one of the problems is
trump is no longer leading because when
he was actually governing
he governed pretty mainstream
conservative there's this sort of
mythology about him like he was
different he really he governed like a
mainstream conservative he was just very
bold about it which is why a lot of us
like me who say like love the way he got
he was
policy wise was excellent
even on the foreign policy front i
thought he was excellent but the radical
right hates foreign policy i mean just
as a as a
i think they would do away with the
state department if they could they do
not want any foreign policy they're
irrationally and emotionally averse to
any kind of american involvement in the
world they call it globalism they call
it you know america lasts and i'm like
well
you know last i checked i'm not sure
that it's america first if china and
russia get to get to form their own
world order while we just sit back and
take it
now
and then the other similarities i would
say between the radical right and
radical left these victimhood grievances
these grievance narratives this this
appeal to that kind of grievance this
outcome-based philosophy
now ironically with the outcome based
philosophy is when it all costs
philosophy ironically
they don't want to win
and you can see that over and over again
they'd rather they'd rather die on a
hill and engage in that kamikaze mission
than win because winning means some
sense of responsibility to go yeah that
that is that is not something they want
it's us versus them it's it's it's this
loyalty it's this it's this constant
testing
and and heretic hunting within the
movement again occurs on the left occurs
on the radical right on the right we
actually have words for we call them
rhinos you know rhino hunting would eric
greitens make this deplorable ad and it
just
utterly become himself by by getting a
gun and saying this is my rhino hunting
gun and i'm gonna go hunt rhinos right
republican and name only it's
it's it's so ridiculous you you kind of
have to laugh at it a little bit but
it's also
it created a toxicity that is really
really unfortunate so let's return to
this issue of criticism of the
fundamental institutions because there's
a lot of that going on there's a huge
cultural movement in the us and the west
more broadly to
make the case that the very principles
upon which our great nations were
founded are in and of themselves corrupt
that america for example is
fundamentally a nation built on
um
the
what would you call it to build slavery
into its system right from the onset
and should be understood primarily as an
oppressive structure whose is continuing
to propagate itself across time
on the right too you have this problem
is if you're going to criticize the
institutions how far do you go down
and i look at the institutions and i
think well
america was founded on the principles
that were originated in no small part in
great britain
and great britain fought for more than
150 years
to end the slave trade
even though they had participated in it
like virtually every other society since
the dawn of mankind somehow they decided
it was wrong and then they fought for
more than a century almost two centuries
to stop the slave trade and they did
that because they're predicated they're
predicated like the u.s on the idea that
each individual is a divine is a locus
of divinity in some inalienable sense
and i'm not willing to criticize that
proposition
i think that when when the the criticism
of the institution goes that far then
well what exactly are you throwing out
here because your very
claim that there's something wrong with
slavery is predicated on acceptance of
the proposition that each individual is
made in the image of god
and that's an institutional claim and so
is that corrupt and if it's corrupt well
then why isn't slavery okay if it's just
about power if it's about some other
principle
so the
the the criticism has to go far enough
obviously
but it can't go too far and we can't
lose this is part of your reference to
tradition and responsibility we can't
use lose sight of the balance between
the law book the statute of liberty is
holding and the flame that's held aloft
and part of that is the tension the
proper tension between the people on the
left and the right you know the right
are going to say well don't forget about
the walls
and the left is going to say well don't
forget about the garden it's like hey
fair enough and where should the walls
be and how much should be garden well we
have to talk about that all the time
there used to be a little bit more
agreement in america on what that looked
like there was a little bit more
agreement on our foundations our
constitution our judeo-christian
heritage and so
there's very little agreement on that
now
maybe more than we realize like i
actually still am somewhat optimistic
that maybe 70 of the public is still uh
largely on the same page and and this
very exhausted silent majority that has
just tuned out from politics i i think
it's probably more than that i think
it's probably 90
that you just hardly need any radicals
especially if they're given free reign
you hardly need any radicals to
destabilize the society plus we've
subsidized a whole number of generations
of people who do nothing but criticize
right and i would say those are the
academics particularly in the woke
humanities it's like they're paid to do
nothing but criticize so it's no wonder
that everything's under assault
well with social media it allows that
that that very small number of people to
to congregate rather quickly affirm each
other's beliefs rather quickly and then
make it appear as though there is there
is some movement happening when there's
really no movement and to mob and to mob
everyone who dares disagree in a very
effective manner like i've watched i bet
i bet i know 250 people now who've been
mobbed
well yeah like yes what's interesting
too is they'll try to mob you so i think
the first video you posted with me
uh whenever we did our last podcast uh
you were mobbed quite viciously online
and that was not from the left that was
from the radical right and so this is
from these this mostly disenchanted
young men frankly that
are so incensed by the idea that you
might be supportive of me
because they're mad at me for some
reason they're not even sure why it's
actually one of the more hilarious
things about my fight with this group of
kind of populist types
is that if you actually ask them
questions about it they usually are
deriving their hatred from some kind of
conspiracy like i like i work for the
world economic forum or i voted for red
flag laws which again isn't true i voted
the opposite
i'm not part of the world economic forum
obviously
uh they they always default to these
very strange conspiracies but what they
if they were telling the truth what they
would say is that dan calls us out dan
calls us out and we don't like that
because fundamentally
we're we're more mafioso than we are
1776.
and fundamentally it's about loyalty and
you know what if we want to move the
goal post a little bit and test your
loyalty by seeing if you'll say the next
thing that is that is more extreme and
more
and and more provocative and we'll test
your loyalty and if you don't if you
don't concede
well you're no longer with us and worse
if you criticize us for it well we'll do
everything we can to destroy you because
you've got too much influence and we
don't like that so that that's what's
that's what's fundamentally behind that
kind of mobbing
on the radical right it's it's like it's
a loyalty test more than anything else
and what's frustrating about it is very
little
separating us policy wise again i think
i think the foreign policy is probably
the key thing
but other than that it's it's difficult
to find actual differences well you you
told me you told me that you've actually
faced this isn't the case for me i faced
way more
trouble from the radicals on the left
than the radicals on the right i've had
my trouble with the radicals on the
right but you know there's no radicals
on the right
causing trouble in the universities like
zero and so because mostly i was in the
universities all the enmity that was
devoted towards me
and everything that's undermined my
profession and my ability to conduct my
business has come from the radical left
but the radical rate has come after me
now and then but you told me that
at least especially in more recent years
you've actually had more trouble from
the radical right than from the radical
left
well i don't know if it's more uh
it's not like i'm it's not like i'm
popular with the left you know and part
of it's like it's primary season and
this is just what happens
but i did tap into i tapped a nerve with
some of these people and a very because
they're threatened they're threatened
that that
that what i want which is the reagan
revolution of conservatism
um
is
is going to displace what they want
which is i mean it's hard to say who
their hero is again i don't actually
even think it's trump well i think i
think their hero is probably something
like
a warrior type you know like at least in
imagination and well they say that
archetype i know i know i know i know
but that but they seem to really hate
any veterans who because veterans tend
to have a sense of loyalty to
institutions and they hate that
um and they they
it's it's a strange thing whatever the
right-wing populists are i actually call
them the woke right
they're woke because there's there's
just so many similarities with the left
and i went over some of them but
you know some of those similarities
again are are an
untethering from long-standing
principles again it's about winning in
the moment it's about that hyper loyalty
it's contrarianism for the sake of being
a contrarian
okay so that might be part of it eh that
might be part of it then because if if
the moral virtue
is to be derived from
merely being contrary right to the point
of conspiratorial thinking and then they
run across someone like you
who is capable of being contrary but who
isn't conspiratorial or contrary in an
arbitrary sense
and then you say well here's the limits
to being contrary well then that's
annoying because
what that means is that you make a
better moral case for your
stalwart reasonableness than they can
make for their arbitrary contrariness
and that arbitrary contrariness that's
just a kind of out that's the kind of
outrage that you already described is
look how virtuous i am because i'm so
upset about this i'm so upset i want to
tear everything down well
how come you're
how are you different than a radical
marxist then because they want the same
bloody thing and for the same moral
reasons
and i'm unconvinced that the many of the
people that are the loudest on this um
they usually have a when i say the
people who am i talking about i'm
talking about mostly like there are some
politicians that fit this bill but
mostly i'm talking about influencers who
run instagram accounts or one run
twitter accounts maybe they're maybe
they write for some sort of fringy
online website whatever it is uh maybe
they're a fox news host
named tucker carlson
in in any case their
their goal their
their goal is contrarianism for the sake
of it and and the word outsider means
everything to them so they create this
incentive structure because they they
they know that that the people respond
to words like outsider first for some of
the reasons that we're we're talking
about right because like everybody who
wants to go to washington just talked
about how corrupt washington is and so
yeah
and some people have this belief that
it's terrible and then you know it's
just like self-fulfilling prophecy it's
a pretty bad situation that we're in and
we've cast a lot of doubt on the
integrity of the institution there by
nature of this
you know election process and how we
talk about it but i don't think that
these people really believe a lot of the
words that they're saying i believe that
they're engaging in the incentive
structure just to be contrarians because
there is an incentive structure there
it's good for their business well
sometimes dan
sometimes being a rebel is the most
is the most
honorable thing you can do but almost
never
but sometimes it is because you're
standing up against the mob you know
and you said
as part of the seal code or at least
associated with it is that you can be a
rebel but not a mutineer it's like so
you're a rebel when you really need to
be and the thing is if you're a rebel
when you really need to be and i think
you are exactly that then that casts a
dim light on those who are just rebels
all the time and who are bringing to
themselves the moral virtue that's
attendant on the stance of the rebel
right
because that has to be done judiciously
like exceptionally judiciously because
most of the time if if you believe
something that everyone doesn't believe
you're wrong most of the time
sometimes everyone is wrong
but boy that better not be the case very
often and if it is the case and you're
the one who's opposing that that's not a
place you want to be even though that's
a place you need to be there is virtue
in that
but so i
well i think the reason you're so
annoying to these people is because as
far as i can tell i hate to compliment
people because it's worse than an insult
in some sense but i do i do always get
the sense of talking to you that you're
the real thing you know you've been fire
hardened in a very interesting way and
so these rebel types who view themselves
as saviors of the institutions or of of
the democracy they'd like to have you in
their camp but they don't because you're
not that guy and i think that's very
galling because it also casts them in an
extremely dim light
and they feel betrayed and one of the
worst human emotions you can feel is
betrayal because they had this ideal
that you were just gonna you were gonna
be that 100 of the time rebel it's a
good way to put it yeah and and when i
say well no i mean i use deductive
reasoning i analyze a situation in front
of me and i say look this is
this is worth your time fighting and
this isn't as true as you think
and telling somebody who holds a very
strong belief about a given issue that
it isn't as true as they think or that
the situation that they're angry about
isn't as true as they think i get this a
lot about
you know world economic form it's a
terrible institution
but i have people like is it worth 100
of your time
is is the conspiratorialness about me
associated with this really worth your
time what effect does this thing have on
you
and
but you know once people get wrapped up
into it they get wrapped up into it so i
i thought i would if you don't mind
because we're coming to the end of this
i thought i might close with
some real practical advice you gave
so so
hopefully some of the people who are
listening to
our conversation are people who are
attracted to and compelled by and even
engrossed in some sense
in this more conspiratorial and
destructive thinking that's
characteristic of the radical right
and so
we might say to those people look you
have a concern with the fact that there
is corruption and that it should be
ameliorated and you don't want to
inflate your moral virtue in
relationship to that because like who do
you think you are and how good do you
think you are you could do something
instead that would be more productive
and so we could say first
political organizations at every level
so
like business communities in small towns
and churches and these low-level
distributed but crucial
social networks are desperate to have
people come and participate so you could
get involved civically and you should
because without that immediate practical
on-the-ground civic involvement the
whole bloody game grinds to a halt and
then you say
all right you want to do something
political young people and listen to
this young people
politics
take it
slow
don't choose a side
just keep learning
and take pride in having an open mind
that's a humility right that allows for
learning you're young you don't know
anything the world's really complicated
it's even more complicated than you
think even if you think it's complicated
but you could learn and you could get
better your opinion on complex matters
should come to you slowly over time
within the context of new facts
and experiences
and you put that in a broader context
too which is attention to detail
so you imagine in your life especially
if you don't have a lot of authority if
especially if you're not high up in a
given hierarchy a lot of your life is
mundane detail and you might think well
what's the
value of that and the answer is well
those details are more important than
you think if you pay attention to them
and so you say attention to detail
is a mantra
in the seal teams that is repeated over
and over
for good reason
details matter
in life and death situations
you ever wonder why we're always doing
inspections in the military why do we
obsess over perfect creases
shiny shoes and crispy made
beds it's simple
and this is a call to adventure and duty
and to proper attention to the details
of your life if you can't get the small
stuff right
if it's beneath you let's say
you won't get the big stuff right
we allow ourselves to sweat the small
stuff to pay attention to detail
because we strive to be
dutiful and detail-oriented
and so i thought that was extremely
important i've tried to do this to some
degree in my books in my writings just
tell people you know that you have us
here's another thought i had dan you
tell me what you think about this
so imagine you're trying to go out there
and figure out what size dragon you
should be
confronted
so how do you figure that out how big
are you what challenge should you take
on
well you want to take on a pretty big
challenge a challenging challenge but
you don't want to get eaten and burnt
and so how do you figure that out well
so imagine that you take on a dragon
maybe it's the environmental apocalypse
and you you see the environmental
apocalypse looming in front of you and
it scares you so badly that you're
paralyzed in in fear and now you're
willing to use compulsion
right so power starts to attract you i
would say you've just learned that that
dragon is too big for you
because you're paralyzed
and because now you're you you're
willing to turn to tyranny as an
antidote to your terror
as opposed to that
that's exactly right as opposed to
persua to a persuasive strategy forward
which you would be able to formulate if
you were the size of the apocalypse
and so then i would say well if you're
terrified out of your mind by the
looming catastrophe
and you're willing to turn to tyranny to
deal with it because it's an emergency
and we have to do what's necessary now
and we have to make everyone comply
then that's evidence from your own
nervous system that you've bitten off
more than you can chew
and that you are possessed by pride as a
consequence and so then what would you
do it's like i don't know exactly
because
when i was dealing with my clinical
clients
and they're looking for a pathway
forward
we're always trying to figure out
well what should you do next
and the answer was always
well
if it's too terrifying you won't do it
so let's set you a challenge maybe
you're socially anxious you have to say
hi
to your to the store keeper in your
corner store and you have to shake his
hand and you have to say your name so
why don't you go do that try that this
week and come back and tell me what
happened and you come back and say well
i i was so afraid i couldn't do it it's
like okay man
the dragon's too big
how about you go into the store and you
just say hi
try that this week and then you scale
back you see you scale back on dragon
size until you find one that you could
beat and you could get some treasure
from but that doesn't paralyze you into
immobility and force you to rely on
compulsion well that this thing the too
big of a dragon pathology seems to be a
a pretty good i think description of our
politics where
you know nobody's interested unless it's
the big thing that's that's highly
unattainable um you know on the left
that's a that's a good one it's climate
change right it's yeah it's it's fixing
everybody's price fixing inequalities
these big enormous it's fixing
everything now at all cost we have to
fix everything right now
at whatever cost it's like no otherwise
we're in crisis
right right and right and a key
attribute of that is to exaggerate the
crisis as much as possible well and the
moral hazard there is well look at me i
see this emergency and here it comes and
it's a big emergency and wouldn't it be
something if i had enough power that and
i'm the only one who can do anything
about it so why don't you just cede all
the power to me
because i'm going to take emergency
action it's like that's a bit of a moral
hazard don't you think isn't it just
kind of a little bit too convenient that
your moral claim happens to dovetail
with your demand for what unlimited
power
you know what trudeau said in canada our
prime minister he said he admired the
chinese communist party because they
could take efficient action on the
climate front it's like okay
okay
fair enough maybe you mean that
there's some prominent americans who've
said the same thing um
you know it's terrifying and when you
were talking about attention to detail
and my advice for young people got me
thinking i listened to last night to
your podcast with um
uh the president of hillsdale college oh
arn larry arn
yeah and he was talking about how the
the students were demanding that he
debate them about a constitutional
convention
and i loved i loved how he how he walked
through this um
it
it struck home with me because there is
this tendency again because of this
loyalty to this constant loyalty testing
this constant is constant competition on
the right of who's the most conservative
it's like well i want to secure the
border well i want to i want to stop all
immigration so i'm more conservative
right and so there's this very strange
for tat and then you start to
question like what i'm sorry what what
principle are you tethered to and how
does that make you more conservative and
so that's apparent that's the story he
was telling basically but he didn't say
this but it was pretty obviously true
and i
that the young people inflamed with with
being the best conservative they can be
say look if you're a real conservative
you want to go real hardcore you want a
constitutional convention
and the way he dealt with that was
saying look i'll debate you on this
but
let it go after that let's not spend too
much time on this because the truth is
you don't really know what you're
talking they didn't say that yeah i'm
not quoting him
but but it gets to my point of
by definition you can't possibly know
really what you're talking about you
just don't have the life experience for
it well that's why you're a student like
why the hell are you at the university
if you're not a student like are you a
student or a professor
if you're a student then you don't know
and if you don't know you don't know
then you're not a student and you should
be somewhere else and the professors too
is like are you the guy who knows at
least something or not are you the equal
of the students well then why are they
paying you it's like why is the
hierarchy set up this way
and the thing is there is nothing more
demoralizing you can tell young people
then you already know everything you
need to know now
i mean jesus i don't want to know that
about me it's like
i know everything i need to know now
it's like what the hell am i going to do
for the next 20 years then
there's no horizon of ignorance to
overcome
i i do think there's a
a crisis of humility
in
our current generation and i do think it
comes from
exposure to the internet and exposure to
quite a bit information
and a total lack of gratitude and
appreciation for for elder wisdom and
look there's an argument to be made that
many that say the baby boomer generation
really screwed some things up for us but
there's a there's a counter argument to
be made that this is still the best time
to be alive in history that's a that's
an important counter argument the whole
best time in history argument and it's
it's just having a sense of of humility
about what state you're really in and
what you really know and that there's a
calming factor to that too that yeah
measure to outrage culture because if
you do think you know everything and
you're so self-righteous that you you'll
die for that belief
well then you're going to be pretty mad
about it and you're going to you're
going to tweet about it and you're going
to chastise others you don't necessarily
agree with you or have some questions at
least as to why you feel so strongly
about this and so that outrage also
serves as a shortcut to argumentation
that's pretty dangerous too
and on the right what's happened is
again that shortcut is usually
is usually a
some kind of epithet like rhino or i'm
more conservative than you so as opposed
to an actual argument about say whether
a constitutional convention makes sense
to to deliver our principles or make
sense for from moving the ball forward
on the field which is a perfectly fine
conversation to have
it just becomes about who's more
conservative which is really just a form
of insulting somebody in order to bypass
strong debate
well i really enjoyed your book thank
you jordan it means a lot to me and oh i
should also point out for everybody
who's listening is that dan maybe you
can say a few words about this you have
a youth conference every year
you want to just talk about that maybe
we'll close with that because this is
something you do that's quite unique and
i think it's quite remarkable and
it's also fun it's leveled with that
sense of humor that we described earlier
and it's an invitation to young people
to participate civically in a
in a positive manner that isn't
it isn't a hallmark greeting card too
no no it's i i love doing it this is our
third year doing it in october uh you
you appeared virtually last year and
answered questions for a lot of the
students
last year we also had ben shapiro we had
michael knowles megan kelly came
uh this year is going to be even even
more eclectic uh we we're going to have
dennis prager
and we'll have michael knowles again
we'll have conservative comedians like
jp sears we'll also have randy hauser
plays a big country star he'll play
saturday night so i want it to be fun
uh we have the wolf of wall street
jordan belfort coming he's going to give
you financial advice so it's just what
i'm trying to create here is a
conservative ted talk series more or
less because
every speaker i work with them i'm going
to make sure we have a particular
message to deliver
and this is different from most
conservative events because if you go to
most conservative events it's it's
political speech after political speech
i'm not sure you're getting a hugely
different message with each one um they
can be fun uh it's a it's those are i'm
just different from those things right
i'm not criticizing say what cpac
it's for a different reason
um i want a liberal student to be able
to walk into my event and come away
thinking those conservatives aren't as
evil and crazy as i thought they were
i i want that to be possible and more
importantly i want because it's majority
conservative students coming to this i
want them to walk away with
better ideas and better ways to
formulate their ideas because a lot of
people these days it gets to that
when i tell young kids like don't make
decisions too early don't get too
adhere too quickly to an ideology
because what a lot of people end up
doing is putting on a red jersey or a
blue jersey and then thinking and then
screaming okay wait wait now what do i
say and why do i say it
like after they put on the jersey and
that's just not how it's supposed to
work right you should it should take a
while for you to get to get to the
decision of what team you want to be on
and this is why the radical left radical
right have such similar traits
because because on the radical right
they're they're wearing red jerseys but
they're basically bernie bros they have
the same disposition like the same the
same kind of kind of animated thought
processes and that's a problem
so i want people to have a better a
better idea of how to work through those
things this year i'm actually upping the
age too if you're older you can just pay
money and come to it so you know i just
i really want to open it up it's really
fun um and i hope you'll appear uh at
least virtually this year as well yeah
well i'd like to attend i think as i'll
definitely attend virtually i'd like to
attend in person at some point i think
i'm touring but but i do think too that
on the conservative front i mean
you're you're an interesting figure
because you're an adventurous guy and
you're a creative guy and you've got a
wicked sense of humor and a real sense
of fun and you know that that adds that
kind of libertarian spice in some sense
to that conservative persona and so
there's a nice balance of like of of of
of tree and snake in that in that
combination and so i think that really
comes out in that youth convention if
you're interested in the youth summit
it's crenshaw youthsummit.com
that was the only that was the only
thing i realized we left out crenshaw
youthsummit.com well thank you and like
i said i really appreciated your book
and also the broader
philosophical and motivational context
that needs to be addressed because the
fundamental culture war isn't happening
within the political domain it's it's
super ordinate to that and i see your
work and the way you conduct yourself in
the political domain
as
reflective of something much deeper and
more profound and necessary
hello everyone i would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com